under high security preparations for a
voyage delayed by more than five months
the rizoni is the first grain ship to
leave odessa since russia's february
invasion loaded with 26 000 tons of corn
it's bound for lebanon via turkey i am
very happy and my crew also
so much happy
to leave
this support
the rizoni is one of 17 grain vessels
that had been stuck here since war broke
out the deal brokered by the u.n with
the help of turkey allows them to leave
ukraine will guide the ships through the
mined waters while russia has agreed not
to target the black sea port during the
shipments
crew members like abdullah say it's a
relief after a scary period in odessa
last month russian missiles hit the port
just a day after the deal was agreed the
merchant vessel razone
is loaded with two commodities in short
supply
corn
and hope hope that the grain trade from
ukraine can soon ramp up again to temper
rising food prices particularly in
africa and the middle east russia and
ukraine are two of the biggest exporters
of wheat and sunflower seeds those
involved in the trade say getting
stranded ships out is one thing
getting fresh vessels into odessa will
be another the main obstacle
is
the cost of insurance for
ship owners
still we don't have firm conditions
how much
do
they have to pay that cost will depend
on the success of the rizoni's voyage
and could yet deter some grain buyers i
think the very first vessels will be old
one which is cheapest one and small one
part of turkey's role is to ensure that
those ships won't smuggle arms into
ukraine
despite the deep mistrust between moscow
and keeve both welcomed the rizzone's
departure a very rare moment where the
two sides agree redmond shannon global
news london